Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today, Ruffians.
It's the end of the week, but it's also the 116th episode!
Not the 115th, no.
Earlier.
Funtime.
Oh my son, it's the 116th episode!
Right!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians, for always being here with us in the morning!
Bye!
Maybe some Ruffians, maybe it's been a little while since your last FUWAMOCO Morning?
Yeah, it needed a bit of a refresher.
Wow, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Are you having a good morning so far, Ruffians?
Pressing the hashtag, hashtag button?
Hashtag.
Hi.
Ya.
What if you wanna start your day off on the left paw?
No!
Oh, my answer is different.
If you wanna start your day off on the left paw, go!
Go for it!
If that will make you smile the most.
You need to start on the right paw, okay?
Not the left one.
Okay, Moco-chan.
Only the right paw.
You go for it, Ruffians.
The left paw is some... You know sometimes it's good to kinda change things up, you know?
Ah, not get unbalanced.
Right, you know.
Left paw!
No.
Right paw.
Yes.
Left paw.
Ah!
Then, Fuwawa's left paw, Moco-chan's right paw.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
I'm done!
That means both paws equal.
A big weekend's coming up!
Yeah!
But we have bad news!
What?
Nothing's been cancelled, why?
No?
What is that?
Apparently... What?
There's been a Pero Sighting.
A Pero Sighting!
That's what we have here!
Where's the picture?
Let's see where he is then.
De-den!
Nothing's there.
Huh?
Still no Pero?
Ruffians!
We heard he had a birthday party.
Right.
Huh?
Where is he?
Why didn't you take a photo of the birthday boy, huh?
Huh?
Well, uh, maybe he like escaped before the Ruffians could get a photo.
Maybe he's off somewhere again.
I don't know.
He was supposed to be back.
Are you sure about that?
Maybe he's preparing for something important.
Huh?
The Pero have important things to do.
I don't know.
He's doing research.
You can ask him what kind of research.
Well...
We'll have to see.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Next time make sure you take a picture, okay?
Picture says if that one works or not.
Then we know!
Exactly where he is.
And... Fuwamoco doesn't need to worry about it.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Well, we'll see!
Good news!
The season.
It's summer!
Finally summer!
And you know what?
We're spending it together with you, our teacher, having fun on a summer camp too!
BAU BAU!
Oh no!
Voice pack!
Academy voice pack!
The Academy voice pack series is back!
It's back!
FUWAMOCO it is!
FUWAMOCO!
They're in our bathing suits together with Noel-senpai and Kanata-senpai!
Yeah!
The key visual!
Right!
BAU BAU!
You know, it was just released out early in the morning, Ruffians.
Really?
But how many of you got your paws on it yet?
Cute!
You saw it, you saw it!
Moco-chan, you're having trouble with a little crab on your head there.
I was feeling a bit crabby, huh?
Oh, there's a lot in them!
You just got it!
Oh, really!
Oh, what did you think, Ruffians?
Oh, you might take it out!
Yeah, we got Fluffy the Fuzzy!
Silver hair, silver hair.
But yeah!
I know!
This time if you want you can check out my introduction video and then kind of see what kind of things happen on a summer trip.
So maybe spicy situations like feeding flowers on shaved ice and uh...
Putting sunscreen on me.
Is sunscreen spicy?
Is shaved ice spicy?
Shaved ice is sweet, Moco-chan.
In what situation is shaved ice spicy?
Well, Ruffians!
If you wanna get an even better listen, you can go to the official hololive shop and listen to some sample voices there!
And then you'll know exactly- Oh!
This is where the voice pack is!
Right?
You might be curious, huh?
We also recorded that, huh?
We recorded it in English and Japanese, so you can- Oh!
What's the difference between them?
You can also have a listen to some of our Senpai's voice packs too!
And their special voices too!
But we always put lots of love and effort into our voice packs, so please go ahead and take them out, okay?
We wanna hear what you thought, okay, Ruffians?
Yeah, you know the academy.
The academy series has been going for a little while now.
A little bit now, but you can jump in now.
Yeah, I know.
But I hear there's some mysterious exchange soon.
It's too hot.
So you can always jump in, okay?
BAU BAU!
Wow!
The summer continues.
And this summer, in only just a few weeks from now, hololive English, we're holding our second concert, Breaking Dimensions, in New York City!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
What's this?
FUWAMOCO after...
Making our brand new 3D debut this weekend!
This weekend!
Of course, we'll be performing there with all of Advent as well!
Yeah!
Yeah, let's go!
Bum bum bum bum!
There's a lot of excitement going on, I think, Ruffians.
But to get you pumped up even more, there's going to be an official program for the concert on the hololive English channel on YouTube here!
The official one.
Not the official one.
You know, maybe there's some new extra information.
Oh yeah, we haven't heard much for a little while.
Right?
You know, Ruffians got their tickets.
Maybe for your streaming.
But it's right before our 3D debut, so it's gonna be a very exciting day, okay?
Yeah, it's happening right before our 3D debut.
But Moco-chan, we actually got something a little bit special that we can share with the Ruffians.
Well, take a look at this!
It's me, Fuwawa!
You look so fluffy and ready to break the dimensions!
Yeah, maybe you'll just have to wait a little bit longer to see exactly how fluffy!
Yeah!
And... Me!
Moco-chan!
Yeah!
Pretty fluffy tail there.
Right!
Yeah!
Like a big puff.
Right!
I look forward to seeing it!
Maybe soon.
Maybe.
You'll have to tune into the program to catch all the latest news on Breaking Dimensions!
Yay!
Maybe there'll be some surprises too.
And then, after that, a 3D debut!
BAU BAU BAU!
But, what did you say?
A fuzzy tail?
I'm the fluffy one.
Did you say fluffy, Taylor?
No, I said fuzzy.
Are you sure about that?
I'm the fluffy one.
She said fluffy.
I'm the fluffy one, I'm Fuwawa!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU!
Speaking of 3D debuts!
Yes!
Someone who's not fluffy, someone who's not fuzzy, will be making their 3D debut today!
And that one is Nerissa!
Nerissa, we be good!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Yeah, she's gonna be taking to the stage just after she released her brand new EP.
Right.
But she'll be making her debut at 8pm PT.
So maybe Ruffians.
Maybe you can get ready, get some coffee, maybe grab, gather some popcorn!
Yeah!
Or some meat!
Meat!
Nerissa always wants some meat!
What do you want to eat, Nerissa?
Meat?
No carbonated soda?
No.
Once you have that all, you can get ready for Nerissa's beautiful boys!
Yeah!
Are you excited, Ruffians?
Somehow!
Bye bye!
We're looking forward to it!
I wonder what Nerissa's gonna do.
We'll have to see very soon.
Only 12 hours!
You have a bit of time to make some popcorn.
If you properly manage your time, you can do it.
12 hours is quite a bit of time to make some popcorn.
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
But, tomorrow...
Tomorrow.
Tomorrow, Ruffians!
That's our big day!
But then we make our 3D debut!
Yes!
Moco-chan.
Which is bigger?
Nervous or excited?
Both.
Both?
Well, I'll be excited.
You'll be nervous?
Yes!
Okay.
Yeah.
We are both.
Ah, yeah!
It's also, you know, not only is it a day that we're really excited and nervous, it's also the day that you find out really just how fluffy and fuzzy we are!
You know, even practicing singing and dancing non-stop!
You know, we worked so, so hard towards this one day!
Yeah.
Ruffians, we hope you know just how hard that we've worked.
How many tears we've shed.
How much we sweat.
It's been a long journey.
It has!
Yeah.
And tomorrow... It's gonna be great.
Well, tomorrow will be the result of all our hard work.
Yeah.
Please, Ruffians, please look forward to the day!
Yeah!
Yeah.
And, Ruffians,
Countdown images!
It says three days left, but it's no longer three days left.
No, it's closer!
Yeah, much closer.
What did you think, Ruffians?
What do you think?
Looking a bit fluffy there.
Yeah!
Are you excited?
Well, I tweeted about how I'm going to put you into a fluffy hair look.
Yeah!
Figuratively.
But it seems like a lot of Ruffians think I might actually... Ruffians?
I'm an idol, you know!
Yeah!
And look, I know.
Well, uh, Ruffians.
Actually, the Great Okan apparently even thinks that there might be some extreme violence too!
Yeah, he responded to us on Twitter!
Yeah!
We're so surprised!
But, uh, the Great Okan is a really famous pro wrestler in Japan!
Yeah!
And also is a huge hololive fan too!
Yeah... But...
Maybe he's confused.
Yeah, I think he's confused too.
We're idols, Ruffians!
Yeah!
Demon dogs!
Got it!
Have you seen me?
Oh!
Wow!
Hi!
Two days left!
Two days!
We're not at two days!
I think a Ruffian is at 36 hours.
Oh, that's like right in between.
Just about.
If you think about it, that's like one day left.
One day plus 12 hours.
Yeah.
Is that 36 hours?
I don't know.
I think.
And there's Moco-chan there!
Yeah!
It's me!
Looking very fluffy!
Fluffy?
A fuzzy.
What is wrong with you today, huh?
It is opposite day!
Opposite day!
I'm sorry for offending you so horribly, Moco-chan.
Thank you!
Thank you for the apology, huh?
Okay, you look fuzzy then!
Got it?
Thank you!
Got it!
That is correct!
Okay.
Yeah, please look forward to it, okay?
BAU BAU!
But we're gonna put our all.
Hopefully we don't make any mistakes.
Make sure you wave your penlights lots and lots on BAU BAU for us too, okay?
Okay, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
36 hours.
August 10th, 8pm PT.
BAU BAU!
Are you sure that's the time?
Yes.
No.
Yes?
Yes.
BAU BAU!
How many times have we been saying it, Moco-chan?
We've said it so much I can't remember anymore.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Wow, now that we remember the important things, let's take a look at the other important things.
Yeah!
Like today's Doggie of the Day!
We have De-den!
Hanzo!
The Doggie of the Day!
I can hear this noise.
Hanzo's cute!
Just like that!
Look at all the rules of the fluffles!
Yeah!
Very, very cute!
But Hanzo loves to nap.
Moco-chan, what did we need earlier?
A nap.
What do we do?
Practice.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
We're glad that Hanzo's getting lots of zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi zi
I will personally make sure that Hanzo always has the freshest, most comfy smelling sheets in the world.
Personal guarantee.
Fuwawa guarantees it.
But you know, maybe FUWAMOCO, maybe we can replace that plushie too.
It does, of course.
Oh, no, it's Pero.
No!
I-I-I-Hanzo looks very comfy there.
I wanna be comfy, too.
I wanna be nice.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, the movie continues!
Let's take a look where your paws have been taking you!
We have De-den!
We're so happy that you were able to go for a nice walk after not being home for a little while.
And with good company.
We're really happy that you were able to rescue her out of the machine.
Had Ayame-senpai to accompany you all the places you've been.
You had some good luck there, huh?
Yeah.
Why?
Thank you for sharing it with us!
Mama!
And next, Moco-chan, do we have a question?
Yeah.
Oh.
For our Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
I was wondering what you would prefer.
If we take many screenshots during our upcoming 3D showcase, or fully focus our attention on enjoying your performance?
Good question.
Well, I think this duet makes you the most happy.
Yeah!
You know, whether that's commenting a lot so that we can see you, or being in a call and BAU BAU-ing together with other Ruffians.
Right!
You know, like a WATCH party.
A WATCH party.
Yeah.
Maybe live tweeting using our hashtag.
That would be nice too.
Don't use the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
No, no, no.
Making memes.
Or being the best photographer ever and sharing your pics.
It's all up to you!
Whatever is the most fun you know.
And you can watch it live and then decide to do that afterwards too!
It's up to you, Ruffians!
Only one hashtag!
The hashtag is... Hashtag!
FWMC3D!
Got it.
Not that hard.
Yeah.
I can't believe it's so soon.
Ruffians!
Do you know what you're gonna do?
Do you have a plan, Ruffians?
I usually tweet afterwards.
That's a strategy too, you know?
It would be cool if... What?
Twins.
That would be cool.
Huh?
FUWAMOCO.
Trending.
Huh?
Trendy.
Trendy means you're up on the times.
But you don't call Twitter, Twitter anymore.
I'm gonna trend on Twitter!
Yay!
If the Ruffians help.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
All your questions, please send us more questions.
There's been some very good questions recently.
Also, your Pero Sightings.
Yay!
I'm sure you can see them around.
Soon.
Maybe.
Just a little bit closer, okay?
And your walks in summertime!
Go out for a walk!
And if you maybe see a very cute doggy, maybe that's the Doggie of the Day!
Let us know with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
And next!
Well, Nerissa's 3D debut is coming up very soon, but before that... Wait!
We have...
De-den!
We're playing the newest hololive game from hololive Indie!
Treasure Mountain.
It looks pretty fun.
It looks really fun, very colorful, very cute!
It looks kinda like a little bit reminiscent of Suica game.
But not.
It's not.
Advent.
Making a mountain.
Treasure.
Oh, with our senpai.
Cause they are the treasure!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, we're gonna give it a shot and... But we'll see how much fun it really, really is.
My angel senpai is very loud in it.
Well, we'll see.
So we're gonna be even louder maybe.
And then, right after that, it's Nerissa's CD debut!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Mama!
Don't forget the time, okay?
She has her own hashtag too.
Can we take a peek at our schedule, Moco-chan?
Just in case you forgot, there's a theory!
Happy debut!
And after that, well, on Sunday at 6pm PT, we're gonna be having an after-party for our debut!
We'll talk about lots of different stuff this night, and our thoughts on stuff all day.
You know, what kind of feelings we put into things, you know.
You definitely wanna hear all the stories.
The entire day!
Okay, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And for all fans today joining us in the archives, we have your FWAMOCO word!
It's... BAU BAU 3D Week!
BAU BAU!
What?
3D weekend!
Weekend!
BAU BAU!
I feel like I heard that one before.
Right!
FUWAMOCO!
Thank you, Ruffians!
After today's FUWAMOCO, well, we might be a little bit more fluffy, a little bit more fuzzy, but we hope that
Just now even more!
And now you'll join us for more mornings!
FUWAMOCO Mornings!
I'm still in this one.
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Zawa Zawa!
BAU BAU!
Kuroyuri!
Hana!
BAU BAU!
Crayon!
Selfie!
BAU BAU!
Togetsu!
Firewood!
BAU BAU!
Unzen miyori!
Side fruits!
BAU BAU!
Doshi!
Our destiny!
BAU BAU!
Jellypaw!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!